hi i'm john c reilly good i'm john c
reilly i'm sarah silverman the wired
autocomplete interview now commences do
it to say like that
autocomplete interview sarah silverman
canadian there is no way that's the
first thing that comes up it's the first
thing that comes up when you're in
Canada I am NOT Canadian but I am from
New Hampshire which is very close to
Canada we could drive to Canada
sarah silverman a vegan I'm a vegetarian
I'm not quite vegan I eat dairy and I
eat eggs except for sometimes if I think
about eggs too much I grew up in farm
country and the neighboring farm my dad
took me to pick out our Thanksgiving
turkey and I picked it out and watched
me the one I pointed to get slaughtered
and I couldn't believe that that's how
meat was made and that was I know I go
dad what were you thinking you guys I
have no idea is Sarah Silverman's a
Disney Princess ha why yes I am
vanellope von schweetz is a princess who
is Jewish which we never really talked
about but I asserted on Twitter and then
it just became canon
she's a Disney princess who has an
attainable waist and wears comfortable
clothes an attainable waist that's
something I've always wanted is Sarah
Silverman in School of Rock
you know I am why do you keep asking you
know she is Google it is Sarah Silverman
Oh in stranger things girl I play the
balls I've never seen celebrities 7 I'm
not in stranger things that's why known
a writer but also another Jewish girl
woman alright I like I said Wynonna like
the country girl how did John see Riley
meet Will Ferrell great great question
well I had just done a movie with Molly
Shannon called never been kissed I was
visiting with Molly in New York and
she's like you would really like this
guy I'm on Saturday Night Live with and
we met on the West Side Highway and I
just remember staring into his eyes
going I feel connected to this man
somehow and the rest is history
movie history how did John see Riley get
famous I would say that you're a
beautiful totally unique singular actor
and no one can do what you do what she
said how many awards does john c reilly
have not I don't have any words I have a
lot of nominations awards are whatever
it's fine I don't need an award we
learned that in the first movie Ralph
doesn't really need a medal to feel
validated did john c reilly really play
the drums in stepbrothers yes I did
yes I really did play the drums and
stepbrothers next question did john c
reilly write the songs and walk hard
great question I didn't write the songs
I wrote some of them I participated in
the lyrics for a lot of the songs but we
have this amazing collection of
songwriters Mike viola Dan Byrne
Marshall Crenshaw Lawton Wainwright
third but I participated on some of them
and got nominated for a Grammy did john
c reilly a terrible question can you
prove I mean I will one day I'm sad to
say that I have not so far okay so we're
gonna go a speed round yes we're gonna
try to answer this next round as fast as
possible what is Sarah Silverman like in
real life nice
what is Sarah Silverman what's your
birthday December 1st
what is Sarah Silverman up to nothing
much what does sarah silverman do that's
a very general question sleeping I like
to watch television and I write and act
happy
what does eat this is a repeat question
give me some cheese and avocado
did I say cheese some crackers yeah but
not me thank you
where is john c reilly from chicago
illinois where did sound C Riley go to
high school brother Rice High School on
the south side of the city of Chicago
where did John see Riley grew up I grew
up on the south side of Chicago see
question number one I got some more
answers for you watch this well Sarah
Silverman ever on Seinfeld yes I was the
one with the Jimmy legs Kramer's
girlfriend I think my name was Emily wow
that's cool was Silverman in Star Trek
Voyager I sure was
Rainn Robinson scientist laughter were
you one of the weird like Ferengi with
the ears and no I was from Planet Earth
they crashed down into 1997 yeah made
out with one of the guys on camera made
out with another one that guy's off
camera that's a scoop I would not tell
you either of their names was Sarah
Silverman on friends no I auditioned for
it once and that was the first time I
was really star struck
Peter Bonners what is john c reilly is
height six one and a half six one and a
half
Wow you read six - I know I know all
right
what is john c reilly is age oh that's a
tough one 53 years old three years young
yeah that's right you're the youngest
you're ever gonna be
that would be what is Johnson Riley's
first movie casualties of war Brian
DePalma 19 something a long time ago
what is john c reilly doing now I'm
sitting right here with Sarah Silverman
answering these questions for record
Ralph - Ralph breaks the internet yeah
what does john c reilly say at the end
of magnolia oh my gosh this is a really
good question it was this monologue that
Paul Thomas Anderson wrote right before
we shot it he's like here I want you to
say this to hurt and it's this long
beautiful monologue about like if you
want to be with me then be with me but I
won't have you saying how you're dumb
and you're stupid and saying these bad
things about yourself because I love you
and I want to be with you that was a
beautiful thing it was a really
beautiful well-written little monologue
about love that's what I say and I love
you guys storyline the best so sir we
just did the wired autocomplete
interview for the people out there in
the Internet that's right John see see
in the movies